mon mari mondrace merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes politologue spécialiste de la
Russie politologue et chercheur au CNRS
et à Sciences Po merci d'être avec nous
à part les Américains les Européens et
le gouvernement ukrainien ont été
sidérés par l'invasion russe en réalité
pourtant la politique de Vladimir
Poutine elle semble assez cohérente
depuis 20 ans c'est prendre sa revanche
sur ce qui s'est passé après
l'effondrement de l'URSS alors nous
avons tous été sidéré parce que tout
simplement cette invasion et monstrueuse
donc même moi qui suis de très près qui
discute tous les jours avec des
collègues ukrainiens et russes bien sûr
on en parlait mais on ne pouvait pas le
concevoir il y avait quelque chose je
crois chez nous parce que nous sommes
encore des des personnes saines d'esprit
et nous et nous résonnons et pour nous
la guerre les bombardements de civils
c'est
c'est un autre monde c'est un autre
univers et vous avez très justement dit
que si nous avons pu
rassembler les Européens après la
Seconde Guerre mondiale c'était avec
l'idée que chaque société chaque État
soit engagé d'abord et avant tout dans
la paix parce que sans la paix il n'y a
pas de bien-être il n'y a pas de de
société il y a pas de prospérité il y a
pas de communication entre les individus
j'aurais juste ajouté que
malheureusement il y a eu la guerre dans
l'ex-Yougoslavie qui est l'Europe qui
est en Europe et je crois que c'est
justement
l'un des sujets
extrêmement important vous avez
mentionné par exemple des gouvernements
polonais et hongrois il ne pose aucun
problème aujourd'hui face à la Russie
ils sont ils sont deux gouvernements et
deux sociétés qui connaissent
parfaitement le fonctionnement du régime
de Poutine et qui sont tout à fait
d'accord pour unir nos forces et
soutenir l'Ukraine on a vu que la petite
réticence tout récemment c'était plutôt
l'Allemagne et l'Italie qui ont bloqué
le vote du
débranchement de la Russie de de Swift
qui c'est qui serait vraiment une mesure
de rétorsion absolument majeur donc je
pense que ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que l'Union européenne elle n'est
pas impuissante
elle a une grande puissance politique
économique nous sommes le premier
partenaire et économique de la Russie ce
qu'il faut pas oublier que si nous
dépendons en partie du gaz et du pétrole
russe c'est que les oligarques et l'État
poutinien dépendent aussi des revenus
des des
hydrocarbures donc l'Union européenne en
réalité est très unis et si Vladimir
Poutine fait cette guerre aux Ukrainiens
et c'est pour ça que je considère que
nous ne devons pas faire la même erreur
que avec les nations de l'ex-Yougoslavie
dans les années 90
considéré que la frontière de l'Union
européenne ou de l'OTAN est strictement
géographique par rapport aux États
membres que leur l'Ukraine est en Europe
comme les Bosniaques les Serbes les
Croates étaient en Europe et sont en
Europe et que nous devons faire un geste
très fort et et que nous attendons nous
depuis des années c'est de proposer dans
les jours qui viennent à l'Union
européenne ça va être discuté au
Parlement mardi par exemple au Parlement
dans une urgence pareil où nous sommes
confrontés à la guerre
les règles doivent bouger mais justement
est-ce qu'il négociation est encore
possible avec Vladimir
dans le cadre du Partenariat oriental
nous avons déjà des relations très
serrées avec l'Ukraine dans tous les
domaines politiques
économique culturelle universitaire et
cetera que l'Union européenne fasse une
proposition de calendrier rapprochée
pour une adhésion à l'Ukraine puisque
nous ne pouvons plus agir sur le plan de
l'OTAN c'est trop tard malheureusement
et que il est très difficile
d'intervenir directement militairement
sur le territoire
ukrainien moi mais mes amis Ukrainiens
notamment des députés Ukrainiens avec
lesquels j'ai parlé hier
demande un geste fort parce qu'ils ont
peur que la population
ne tiennent pas trop longtemps il y a un
côté aussi je veux dire physique et
psychologique s'il y a pas d'issue c'est
quand même 8 ans qu'ils ont
ils peuvent ne pas tenir donc
donnons-leur au moins tu peux pas y
avoir un accord international avec
Vladimir Poutine sur en échange
plus et on a vu comme notre président de
la République à tout essayé il a été
très loin je dirais à essayer de parler
pendant des heures avec un homme donc il
était il est très clair pour moi depuis
des années que cet homme est toujours
prêt à échanger parce que pour sa
stature diplomatique c'est important
mais que avant même de recevoir ou
Macron ou Scholl ce chancelier allemand
ou Anthony blinken ou Biden il sait déjà
qu'il ne va absolument rien négocier et
c'est ce qui a conduit à à cette
décision absolument désastreuse et pour
vous il va mettre la main sur sont
partis pour prendre Kiev et démembrer
toutes l'Ukraine
je ne sais pas je me suis trompé la
semaine dernière la guerre me paraissait
tellement suicidaire pour Poutine son
régime et les sacs 140 millions de russe
il faut savoir Poutine c'est pas son
pays les 140 millions de Russes ils ne
veulent surtout pas la guerre ils se
sentent proche des Ukrainiens ils sont
eux bombardés par la désinformation de
leur propre télévision
à la fois en Syrie voilà pour le moment
d'ailleurs je pense que pour répondre à
votre question
ce qui va être pour nous
vraiment un signe c'est est-ce qu'ils
vont envoyer la troupe avec des
conscrits
dans des rues de villes ukrainienne mais
c'est envisageable vous pensez
vite la grande prix Nobel de littérature
biélorusse elle a écrit un livre
sur les corps des soldats soviétiques
qui revenaient d'Afghanistan pour ceux
qu'on mettait encore dans un cercueil
qui était des cercueils en zinc c'est
tout ce qui recevait la famille donc il
y a des associations de maire de soldats
qui existent toujours en Russie de
depuis lors et qui sont qui ont une très
très forte audience encore en Russie
quand les cercueils de zinc commenceront
à revenir en Russie il faudra voir donc
je crois que les les comment ils peuvent
mettre en pardon comment il peut avoir
un scénario d'accord il pourrait pas
mettre en place un régime fantoche parce
que s'il y a un régime fantôme ça veut
dire une occupation militaire durable il
peut pas faire ça parce que au fond
l'occupation d'abord on oublie que
l'Ukraine est plus grande que la France
qui a plus de 40 millions d'habitants
des villes très développées je sais pas
si vous avez la chance d'aller déjà à
Kef alvif ha ha c'est c'est un pays
extrêmement
cultivé développer magnifique en terme
d'architecture aussi voilà c'est
vraiment le cœur de l'Europe de l'Europe
centrale donc pour
occuper militairement un pays au 21e
siècle il faut aussi le gérer
ils ont absolument pas le moyen de gérer
un pays développé très proche déjà de
l'Europe et avec cette ouverture sur la
mer Noire enfin un pays commerçant et
j'en ai pour preuve là j'espère ne pas
me tromper c'est que le régime coutinien
ne gouverne déjà plus la Fédération de
Russie moi je suis de très près ce qui
se passe dans les républiques du Nord
Caucase elles ne sont plus gouvernées
par Moscou si vous parlez avec des
sibériens que soyez écoute ce que
rabatros qui est en protestation contre
Moscou depuis au moins 2 ans parce qu'on
a mis en prison leur gouverneur élu
alors gouverner les Ukrainiens qui sont
extrêmement mobilisés déterminés il se
défendent de manière extrêmement
courageuse
[Musique]
je crois pour éduquer certains de nos
fonctionnaires européens et de nos
députés sur la réalité du du pouvoir
poutinien donc je crois que oui nous
avons un problème en France comme dans
quelques autres pays européens sur
cette
étrange justification d'une violence
extrême
utilisée par un dictateur très corrompu
par ailleurs sous prétexte que parce que
il est le successeur d'un empire il y a
plus de 100 ans il aurait quelque part
un droit ou une sorte de justification
émotive romantique c'est insupportable
nous sommes bien d'accord
Emmanuel Macron lui-même a été un petit
peu tenté par cette ligne dure en
2018-2019
sur les accords de mise pour pousser le
président ukrainiennes qui a fait des
concessions sur les
occupations de l'Est du donne pas on
voit où ça nous a conduit merci beaucoup
Marie mandra merci beaucoup